[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und Norbert
du hast die sportmeldung des Tages dabei
übertragen die Frauenfußball WM im
Sommer schon genannt und wir schauen auf
unsere großen Nachrichtenthemen
gegen Gefahren von innen und außen die
Bundesregierung einigt sich auf einen
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
Drama im Mittelmeer beim Untergang eines
Flüchtlingsbootes vor Griechenland
sterben mindestens 78 Menschen
und 200 € für Kultur wer in diesem Jahr
18 ist oder wird kann Geld für
Veranstaltungen Museen oder Bücher
bekommen
[Musik]
das ist selten der Kanzler und gleich
vier Ministerinnen und Minister zusammen
in der Bundespressekonferenz und das
große Aufgebot präsentierte etwas das
ist so noch nie gab eine nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie für Deutschland
deren Zweck alle Bedrohungen von innen
und außen zusammen in den Blick zu
nehmen das sei nötig weil sich die
Sicherheitslage dauerhaft verändert
entscheidend vor allem der russische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine außerdem
Naturkatastrophen wie im Aal vor knapp
zwei Jahren und auch Terroranschläge wie
der auf dem Berliner Breitscheidplatz
Ende 2016 so wie Cyberangriffe im
Internet
laut Regierung könnten diese Bedrohungen
noch zunehmen und nur von verschiedenen
Behörden gemeinsam abgewehrt werden
Butter Spiekermann
sie kommen zu Fuß so lässt sich
Geschlossenheit wohl leichter
demonstrieren die Stimmung ist entspannt
schließlich hat der Kanzler Geburtstag
doch die Lage ist ernst wie lange nicht
sicherheitspolitisch denkt die Ampel um
zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte unseres
Landes haben wir eine nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland erarbeitet
der löwent Anteil dieser Arbeit ist
unter Federführung der Außenministerin
verrichtet worden die zeitenwände die
der Bundeskanzler so deutlich
ausgesprochen und geprägt hat hat die
Dringlichkeit gezeigt dass wir uns beim
Thema Sicherheit anders neu aufstellen
müssen nämlich integriert die Regierung
bekennt sich zu steigenden
Militärausgaben sucht Distanz zu China
und international neue Partner die
cybersicherheit ist ein wichtiger
Baustein wie auch der Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel zudem geht es um eine
stabile Energieversorgung und den
Katastrophenschutz viele Bundesländer
sind nicht zufrieden sie sich Planung
nicht eingebunden so verdient die
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie der Namen
nicht es ist bestenfalls die
Sicherheitsstrategie der Bundesregierung
eine Art nationaler Sicherheitsrat wie
in den USA wird es nicht geben
Außenministerium und Kanzleramt konnten
sich über den Vorsitz nicht einigen
festgeschrieben ist aber das Ziel zwei
Prozent des Bruttoinlandsprodukts für
Verteidigung auszugeben in den nächsten
Jahren das ist kein Selbstläufer es
bedeutet nämlich dass andere Aufgaben
die ebenfalls wünschenswert sind oder
von den Menschen erbeten werden dass die
gemessen werden müssen an unseren
überragenden sicherheitspolitischen
Interessen Russland sei die größte
Bedrohung für Sicherheit und Frieden
betont wird die enge Zusammenarbeit
innerhalb Europas und mit den USA
es gab ja vorher schon Leitfäden zur
Sicherheit Theo Koll was ist das
grundlegende neue an dieser nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie also neu daran ist
der Versuch die Folgen der zeitenwände
umfassend und langfristig unter
Sicherheitsaspekten zu denken und
aufzuschreiben und zwar für alle
regierungsressourcen also weit über
klassische Verteidigung oder Rüstung
hinausgehen da geht es um alle Bereiche
der nationalen Sicherheit bis hin zum
Katastrophenschutz oder wirtschaftlichen
Lieferketten gehandelt wird ja danach
eigentlich schon längst seit dem
russischen Überfall Reisen Kanzler und
Co ja um die Welt werben um neue Partner
um neue Rohstofflieferanten letzteres
insbesondere um sich von China
unabhängiger zu machen zum Umgang mit
dieser neuen Weltmacht bleiben die
Aussagen allerdings noch sehr schmale
lippig die seit langem angekündigte
China Strategie die steht noch aus und
der von vielen Experten geforderte
nationale Sicherheitsrat quasi um eine
rundum Koordinierung aller Ressorts der
ist in den ampelintern reingeleint zum
Opfer gefallen ins gesamt ist es aber in
Sicherheitsfragen erstmalig einen Art
360 Grad Blick wenn auch mit ein paar
Unschärfen und blinden Flecken vielen
Dank für diese Einschätzung
blicken wir auf das heizungsgesetz das
steht ja jetzt in groben Zügen seit der
gestrigen Einigung der Ampelkoalition
auf was also müssen wir uns einstellen
worauf wurde sich geeinigt und was
schwebt noch in der Luft das zeigt Ihnen
jetzt Claudia Weiler
gelten soll das Gebäude Energiegesetz ab
dem 1 Januar und zwar erstmal nur für
Neubauten dort müssen Heizungen dann
zumindestens 65% mit erneuerbaren
Energien betrieben werden zum Beispiel
durch eine Wärmepumpe für Häuser im
Bestand gibt es eine Übergangsfrist und
zwar bis die Kommune eine wärmeplanung
hat bis 2028 soll es soweit sein Ziel
ist die Fernwärme auszubauen und sie auf
erneuerbare umzustellen
bestehende Öl und Gasheizung bleiben
erlaubt und dürfen repariert werden auch
der Einbau neuer Gasheizungen soll
erlaubt bleiben wenn sie auf Wasserstoff
umrüstbar sind ebenfalls möglich bleibt
Heizen mit Holz oder Pellets und es sind
Ausnahmen geplant für ältere
Hauseigentümer etwa oder soziale
Härtefälle eine Förderung für den Umbau
soll es geben wie hoch genau und für wen
ist allerdings noch unklar
diese Woche soll das heizungsgesetz
erstmals im Bundestag beraten werden wie
die Reaktion auf die geplanten
Regelungen sind und wie kommunale
wärmeplanung funktionieren kann denn auf
die kommt es jetzt ja an das berichtet
Jürgen
Bruchsal im badischen hat die
Hausaufgaben schon erledigt vier Jahre
Arbeit die kommunale wärmeplanung für
die 45.000 Einwohner Stadt ist
abgeschlossen und damit der Weg in einer
klimafreundlichere Zukunft vorgezeichnet
das ist schon relativ weit aber
natürlich kommen jetzt die Mühen der
Ebenen das auch umzusetzen die nächsten
Jahre oder dafür braucht es Geld dafür
braucht es Mut und die Leidenschaft aber
die haben wir auch Vorbild Bruchsal wie
könnte eine kommunale wärmeplanung
funktionieren zunächst wird er ist
Bestand ermittelt wie wird geheizt
welche Infrastruktur gibt es dann welche
klimafreundlichen Potenziale schlummern
wo Erdwärme etwa oder Biomasse
schließlich müssen Projekte möglichst
schnell umgesetzt werden Bruchsal hat
etwa ein eigenes fernwärmekraftwerk
gebaut ein neues Angebot im südlichen
Stadtviertel wo man umweltfreundliche
Energie zu kommen gut sagen auch die
Klimaschützer doch bis 2028 sollen die
Kommunen und planen dürfen dass er viel
zu lang
die Einigung der Koalitionen beim
gebäudeenergiegesetz ist leider keine
gute Nachricht für den Klimaschutz weil
nämlich die Einigung zu Lasten der
klimaschutzwirkung dieses Gesetzes ging
und die Klimaschutzziele damit in weite
fernrücken kritik gibt es auch Vermieter
Bund denn die Wohnungsmieten könnten
nach dem Einbaum moderne Heizungsanlagen
zusätzlich steigen
es kann nicht sein dass dafür eine
zusätzliche Modernisierungsumlage
geschaffen wird und damit der Mieter das
bezahlen soll im Ergebnis das halten wir
für völlig falsch die zusätzliche
Motivation finanzieller Art muss durch
staatliche Fördergelder erfolgen so
langsam zu teuer in Bruchsal gilt das
nicht das neue Energieangebot ist schon
damals geschneidert im Sommer vor allem
Solar im Winter kommen vermehrt
Holzpellets dazu aus der Region
das Mittelmeer ist heute wieder zum Grab
geworden mindestens 78 Menschen
ertranken als ihr Flüchtlingsboot vor
Griechenland kennterte und untergehen
die
Opferzahl könnte noch deutlich steigen
denn mehrere hundert Menschen gelten
weiter als vermisst mit einer groß
angelegten Rettungsaktion wird von der
Halbinsel Peloponnes nach ihnen gesucht
und das passte berichtet
die Strapazen sind den Überlebenden ins
Gesicht geschrieben als sie im Hafen von
Kalamata an Land kommen sie gehören zu
den 104 die nach dem Schiffsunglück
bislang gerettet wurden schon seit dem
Morgen stehen Krankenwagen bereit um
Verletzte zu behandeln die meisten
kommen in einem provisorischen Camp am
Hafen unter das haben Teams in
Zusammenarbeit mit der Gemeinde und der
Präfektur aufgebaut um der ganzen
Situation hierher zu werden
es ist eine schwierige Operation es ist
die zahlenmäßig bisher größte
Rettungsaktion die wohl bisher
schwierigste die der griechische Staat
durchführen musste
auch die Luxusyacht Mayen Queen vor hat
kurz nach Mitternacht am Unglücksort
viele Schiffbrüchige aufgenommen Welten
treffen in diesem Moment auf dem
Mittelmeer aufeinander
der Fischkutter mit mehreren hundert
Migranten an Bord so laut griechischen
Behörden in der libyschen Stadt Tobruk
gestartet sein das Ziel sah Italien
gewesen
frontextet das völlig überladene Schiff
in internationalen Gewässern von Pylos
griechische patrouillenschiffe hätten
Versorgung und Hilfe angeboten diese
habe die Besatzung aber abgelehnt in der
Nacht dann SOS das Schiff kentert neben
der Luxusyacht beteiligen sich einen
Dutzend weitere Schiffe an der
Rettungsaktion
das Wichtigste ist dass viele gerettet
werden und wir hoffen von einer großen
Zahl zu hören die hierher gebracht
werden und wir nicht noch mehr Tote zu
beklagen haben
Griechenlands Staatspräsidentin reist
noch am Abend zu den Helfern und
geretteten und drückt ihre Anteilnahme
aus wie viele Menschen überlebt haben
ist noch unklar über 400 Passagiere
könnten auf dem Schiff gewesen sein
viele von ihnen werden auf dem
Mittelmeer noch vermisst
weltweit sind so viele Menschen auf der
Flucht wie nie zuvor das sagt der
aktuelle Bericht des
un-flüchtlingshilfswerkes demnach sind
es 110 Millionen doppelt so viele wie
noch vor zehn Jahren vor allem weil die
Krisen und Konflikte weiter zunehmen die
größte Gruppe unter den Flüchtlingen
kommt das Syrien mit 6,5 Millionen nicht
gefolgt von Betroffenen aus Afghanistan
und der Ukraine
künstliche Intelligenz eine Seite sagt
ki-systeme wie Chat GPT können uns den
Alltag erleichtern durch das
Sekundenschnelle Erstellen von Texten
oder Bildern die andere sieht KI als
potenzielle Gefahr für die Menschheit
die große Frage ist wie reguliert man
künstlich Intelligenz das
Europaparlament hat dazu heute ein
Gesetzentwurf auf den Weg gebracht als
erste Institution überhaupt weltweit
mehr dazu von Isabell Schäfers beim
data-festival in München wird klar dem
Einsatz von KI sind wenig Grenzen
gesetzt in dieser Simulation etwa
steuert eine KI den Zugverkehr die
letzte Entscheidung soll aber weiterhin
ein Mensch treffen grundsätzlich sehe
ich eine starke Chance in Europa dass
wir sozial und Mensch zentriert KI
nutzen können nur wir sollten ihm
anwendungsspezifisch regulieren wir
sollten sagen das darf man mit Kai tun
das aber mit KI nicht tun diesen
Balanceakt versucht die EU mit einem
neuen ki-gesetz das Ziel die Risiken von
K i begrenzen dafür sollen ki-systeme
künftig in Risikogruppen eingeteilt
werden KI mit inakzeptablem Risiko soll
komplett verboten werden darunter fallen
weniger Ausnahmen wie etwa
Gesichtserkennung in Echtzeit im
öffentlichen Raum für Anwendungen mit
hohem Risiko soll es verschärfte Regeln
geben unter anderem Transparenz und
Dokumentationspflichten Anwendungen mit
begrenztem oder keinem Risiko sollen
größtenteils unreguliert bleiben
wenn wir sagen es besteht ein Risiko ist
die Frage ja ein Risiko wofür und das
Risiko ist eben eine Verletzung von
Menschenrechten und ethischen Standards
ob das in der Gesundheit ist ob eine
Operation notwendig ist ob es die
Vergabe eines Kredits ist ob es die den
Ausblick auf einen Job ist dass das von
einer KI entschieden wird sondern da
haben wir das Gefühl muss noch mal
jemand auch menschlich drüber gucken die
EU will mit den neuen Regeln auch
weltweites Vorbild sein doch zunächst
stehen noch die Verhandlungen zwischen
Parlament Mitgliedstaaten und
EU-Kommission an
in Italien haben tausende Menschen bei
einem Staatsbegräbnis Abschied von
Silvio Berlusconi genommen vor dem
Mailänder Dom versammelten sich Anhänger
des ehemaligen Ministerpräsidenten zum
Gottesdienst kam zahlreiche
Politikerinnen und Politiker auch
Ungarns Regierungschef Orban
Berlusconi war am Montag im Alter von 86
Jahren gestorben er hatte bis 2011 mit
Unterbrechungen vier Regierungen
angeführt
wer heute in die Apotheke wollte stand
mitunter vor verschlossenen Türen denn
die Apotheken haben zu einem Protesttag
aufgerufen sie klagen über
Personalmangel Lieferengpässe und zu
geringe Honorare
gab es zum Jahrtausendwechsel noch rund
21.600 Apotheken waren es letztes Jahr
noch knapp über 18.000 in mehreren
Städten gab es zum Aktionstag
Demonstration und Kundgebungen ein
Bericht von Fabian Köhler
die landapotheke von Stefanie Strube
Plaschke im niedersächsischen
Schellerten bleibt heute zu die
37-Jährige Apothekerin sorgt sich
zunehmend um Ihre unternehmerische
Zukunft die Gründe unter anderem hohe
Arbeitsbelastung durch
medikamentenmangel immer weniger
Personal gestiegene Lohnkosten
deutschlandweit treibt das die Apotheken
in den Protest
wir bekommen pro Packungen einen
festzuschlag und dieser festzuschlag der
muss dringend erhöht werden wir
benötigen darüber hinaus faire und vor
allem wirksame Maßnahmen zur Bewältigung
der lieferenpasskrise und wir benötigen
dringend entbürokratisierende Maßnahmen
für ein verschreibungspflichtiges
Medikament bekommt eine Apotheke von den
Krankenkassen ein Fest Honorar von 8,35
€ hinzu kommt ein Aufschlag von 3% vom
Einkaufspreis für die Vorfinanzierung
des Arzneimittels direkt abgezogen wird
wiederum der sogenannte gkv-abschlag von
2 € größter Kritikpunkt das Fest Honorar
wurde zuletzt 2013 leicht angehoben die
Kernforderung jetzt eine Erhöhung auf 12
Euro für die Bevölkerung steht auf dem
Spiel dass die wohnordner Versorgung
zusammenbricht dass die Akutversorgung
mit wichtigen Arzneimitteln wie
Antibiotika etc nicht gewährleistet ist
doch die Krankenkassen haben weder
Verständnis für den Streik noch für die
Forderung
man muss sich mal eins deutlich machen
das was die jetzt fordern nur für diesen
sogenannten fixzuschlag pro Packung
würde den Mehreinnahmen von 2,2
Milliarden Euro einbringen ohne dass ich
für die Versicherten für die Patienten
und Patienten irgendwas ändert so bleibt
abzuwarten ob die protestdosis der
Apotheken wirklich ihre Wirksamkeit
entwickelt
rammsteinsänger Till Lindemann wird
sexualisierte Gewalt vorgeworfen jetzt
ermittelt ihr Berliner
Staatsanwaltschaft zuvor hat mehrere
Frauen teilweise anonym beschrieben wie
junge Frauen auf ramsteinkonzerten
gezielt für Sex mit dem Sänger
rekrutiert worden sein sollen teilweise
unter dem Einsatz von Drogen
zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe will die
Bundesregierung mit dem Kulturpass
schlagen der ab heute Geld alle in
Deutschland die dieses Jahr ihren 18
Geburtstag haben können ihn bekommen
geschenkt er hat einen Wert von 200 €,
wie sie etwa für Konzerte Bücher
Musikinstrumente ausgeben können junge
Leute sollen so für die Kulturszene
begeistert so wie Kulturschaffende nach
der coronazeit unterstützt werden
in diesem Oberstufenkurs der
Stadtteilschule Walddörfer in Hamburg
ist der Kulturpass heute
Unterrichtsthema hier sind die meisten
dieses Jahr 18 geworden oder werden es
noch für diese Generation sind die 200
Euro auch eine kleine Entschädigung für
die Zeit der lockdowns wir haben schon
einige soziale Probleme dadurch aber
doch also es hilft schon würde ich sagen
ins Kino gehen mit dem Geld ich würde
eigentlich gerne in eine Oper gehen
damit ich mir das auch mal anschaue um
an das kulturguthaben zu kommen muss man
erst die App herunterladen zur Prüfung
des Alters ist ein Digital lesbarer
Person nötig der schaltet das Guthaben
in Höhe von 200 € frei bezahlt wird per
QR-Code bei den Betrieben die sich
registriert haben dazu gehören zum
Beispiel auch Buchläden wie etwa der
Comic room in Hamburg also das dann
Leute den Kindern Film sehen und dann
sagen okay
dazu gibt es auch Comics jetzt habe ich
nutze ich einfach den Kulturpass Rheine
Online-Anbieter wie Streaming Dienste
oder Verkaufsplattformen sind nicht
erlaubt es geht um Kinos Theaters
Festivals Konzerte die Kulturbetriebe
von nebenan ich hoffe vor allen Dingen
dass wir Menschen erreichen die sonst
sich vielleicht auch gesagt haben kann
ich mir gerade nicht leisten geht nicht
der sagen doch jetzt geht's wieder und
damit auch aktiv eine Unterstützung von
teilhabung kulturellen Leben sein kann
rund 750.000 junge Menschen in
Deutschland haben Anspruch auf den
Kulturpass ist das Projekt erfolgreich
sollen mehr Jahrgänge nach und nach dazu
kommen
so und jetzt kommen wir zur guten
sportnachricht des Tages ZDF von ARD
übertragen nun doch die Frauenfußball WM
in Australien und Neuseeland ja wohl ja
alle 64 Spiele zu sehen live im
Fernsehen oder online darauf haben sich
die beiden Sender und die FIFA heute
geeinigt das Eröffnungsspiel 20 Juli in
der ARD die erste deutsche Begegnung
gegen Marokko am 24 im ZDF
der Pokal ist schon da am anderen Ende
der Welt und jetzt auch die Gewissheit
dass ein breites Publikum den Spielen
der 32 Teams in Deutschland wird
zuschauen können das ist eine gute
Nachricht die Fußball-Frauen
Weltmeisterschaft ist im Freien
empfangbaren Fernsehen und zumal im
öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen zu
sehen und wir werden das Ereignis was
eines der großen und wichtigen
Ereignisse in der Sportwelt in diesem
Jahr ist nicht nur live übertragen mit
allen Spielen sondern natürlich auch in
gewohnter Weise publizistisch begleiten
zur Einstimmung bleibt nur noch ein paar
Wochen Zeit der weiße Rauch ist gerade
noch rechtzeitig aufgestiegen bei den
Verhandlungen mit dem internationalen
Fußballverband FIFA die Gespräche
zwischen der FIFA die ja die rechtegeber
sind und ardn ZDF haben tatsächlich
länger gedauert dass der hat sich immer
sehr bemüht um die rechte und hat auch
klar und auch wie ich finde sehr
angemessen Angebote gemacht und ich bin
froh dass gemeinsam mit der EU und
anderen europäischen öffentlich
rechtlichen Anstalten es gelungen ist
jetzt zu einer Einigung zu kommen
neben Spielen und Toren sind auch
mehrteilige Dokus über das deutsche Team
zu sehen vor dem Anlauf zum dritten WM
Titel
jetzt ist es fix BVB-Star Jude
Bellingham spielt nächste Saison bei
Real Dortmund und Madrid haben letzte
Vertragsdetails geklärt Ablöse
mindestens 103 Millionen Euro
heute in einem Jahr startet der
fußball-heim EM der Männer Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz läutete am Vormittag in
Berlin mit der DFB-Spitze den Countdown
ein alles soll so werden wie damals
hierzulande bei der WM 2006 Deutschland
ein Sommermärchen
Heimspiel im kanzlergarten Olaf Scholz
empfängt die DFB-Spitze um Präsident
Neuendorf und Turnierdirektor Politik
und Sport erhoffen sich von der EM eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche
Aufbruchsstimmung ich freue mich
jedenfalls dass es jetzt losgeht und
dass wir das alles hier gemeinsam heute
beginnen weil genau einem Jahr geht's
los
ausgerechnet das Team des Gastgebers
spielt wenig einladend schwächelt denn
die Kritik geraten fliegt und Spieler
besuchten heute ein Fanfest in Frankfurt
so langsam wird es Zeit die Vorfreude
auf die EM zu wecken wir wollen uns als
Land präsentieren und als Verband der
sympathisch rüberkommt als weltoffen und
freundlich doch wenn er allein wird
nicht reichen um eine EM Euphorie
auszulösen
aber ich freue mich jetzt schon drauf
und diese Lottozahlen wurden heute
gezogen die Gewinnzahlen lauten 12 15 17
21 29 44 Superzahl ist die fünf weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de
und im ZDF Text auf Seite 57
Temperaturen um 25 Grad viel Sonne und
höchsten im höchstens im Osten einige
Schauer und Gewitter diese
wetterkombination bleibt uns vorerst
erhalten Details gleich von Katja
horneffer das heute journal läuft um
21:45
[Musik]
guten Abend von Osten ziehen jetzt
gerade ein paar Wolkenfelder rein sie
sehen hier sehr schön wie sich die
Quellwolken auch weiter Richtung Westen
ausgebreitet haben auch Niedersachsen
Rheinland-Pfalz und Hessen und
Baden-Württemberg erreicht haben heute
Nacht sind die Wolken im Osten etwas
dichter im Westen das ist nach wie vor
klar und der Meinung und am Rhein sowie
an den Küsten von Ost und Nordsee sinken
die Werte auf 14 Grad deutlich kühler
wird hier in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen bis zu 5 Grad und morgen
liegen die Höchsttemperaturen an der
Ostsee und auch wiederum in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen um die 20 Grad
sonst gibt's angenehme Werte um 25 Grad
mit 28 Grad wird es am Niederrhein am
wärmsten und auch morgen geht's wieder
viele Quellwolken und dann kann sich
hier in Brandenburg aber vor allen
Dingen rund um die östlichen
Mittelgebirge mal ein Regenschauer oder
ein kurzes Gewitter entwickeln der Wind
kommt meist noch aus nordöstlichen
Richtungen an der Nordsee hat ja schon
auf Nordwest gedreht und mit diesem
Nordwestwind geht in den nächsten Tagen
weiter dann kann es am Samstag
vielleicht auch in Schleswig-Holstein
mal für einen Regenschauer reichen sonst
wird es Schränken sich Regenschauer und
Gewitter aber auf die Osthälfte und am
Sonntag wird es von Südwesten schwül
heißt guten Abend